よろしくお願いいたします
さあそして一緒にイベント盛り上げて
いただく方々ご紹介いたしましょうまずは
競技解説高森哲太
のいい競技解説を目立ちます坂本です
よろしくお願い致します
今回はねバスケットボールに詳しくない方
にも楽しんでいただけるように
早く解説をお願いいたしますはいそうし
ましたそして
川崎ブレイブサンダー2応援リーダーとし
て辻井ライターはい皆さんこんにちは
初めましての方のいらっしゃると思います
が
川崎ブレムサンダース応援リーダー務め
ます私辻井大地ですそして
ファミリーの皆さんお久しぶりです
今日もよろしくお願いしまーす
富士山はこうブレイブサンダースの皆さん
と深い交流があると伺っていますが
ありがとうございます皆さん
本日
背番号7番
篠山竜青選手の
髪型パーマなってるんですけど
実は今日に合わせたらしいので
皆さんそこ注目してみてください
早速ポイントありがとうございます
ありがとうございますはい
スタートしてクリエイターオールスターズ
応援リーダー水田のリボンのトミーさん
はいどうも水溜りのトミーですよろしくお
願いします
よろしくお願いします
トミカ改めてすごい熱気ですね
すごいですね僕何回か完成にさせて
いただいているんですけどもまあその時は
またちょっと違ったお祭りのような
メッキを感じますね今日は皆さんね
盛り上がっていきましょう
プロバスケットボールチームに挑む
クリエイターチームなんですね
トミーさんの見立ていかがでしょうかそう
ですねまあやっぱその実力というか
バスケットボールのうまさではやっぱり
プロにはかなわないと思うんですけども
やっぱその
ファンの応援の力ですとかまあここぞと
いうところの発想力みたいなのは
めちゃくちゃクリエイターの力っていうの
は計り知れないものがあるんでちょっと
期待大なのかなっていうのはありますね
我々の度肝を抜いてくるようなねそうです
ね
さあ2チームのチームカラーなんです
けれども川崎ブレイブサンダースはお
なじみのブレイブレット
対するクリエイトチームハワイアンブルー
ということでこれあのはじめしゃちょーが
考えたらしいんですが
濃い赤に対しては
爽やかな薄
青で行くんだというお話でしたそうですね
僕も今着てるんですけどもかなりの数の人
が来てるんじゃないかなと思いますね今
そうですね本当に多くの方が来てくださっ
ているなぁという印象ですいいですね本当
に
チームからのグッズみんなそれぞれ持って
きてくれてるなとはいもうめちゃくちゃ
売り切れも出てるみたいでですねもう
みんなあ
みんな手振ってますねありがたいですね声
出せないので
盛り上がっていただければとあと始めさん
のチャンネルって日本一大きいんですけど
今生配信始まってて僕1人で出てるのが
すごい怖いです
はじめさんに出てほしい大丈夫に出てくる
からここ僕1人は持たない
嬉しいですね84000人の始めさんの
ファンが見てるのにどちらがしか出てない
怖い頑張れ
頑張ろうもうちょっとだからはいすいませ
んよろしくお願いしますはい配信をご覧の
皆さんもねぜひ盛り上げていただければと
いうふうに思います
後半戦はですね
川崎ブレイブサンダースのYouTube
チャンネルにてえ生配信を行っていくと
いうことなんですが
辻さん
後半戦もこれかなり楽しみですねそうです
ね
後半戦は川崎ブレイブサンダースと
クリエイターチームがごちゃ混ぜになるん
ですねはじめしゃちょー率いるレジェンド
チーム対智也
新世代チームで試合を行いますこの
イベントでしか見られない光景ですので
非常に楽しみですねあと最後にこの
イベント当社MVPが
発表されますのでそのヒーロー
インタビューも楽しみです最後まで盛り
だくさんの内容となってますので
後半戦はぜひ
川崎ブレイブサンダースのYouTube
チャンネルでお楽しみくださいはい
よろしくお願いいたしますさあ前半戦は
このまま始め社長のチャンネルで後半戦は
川崎ブレイブサンダースのチャンネルで
こちらですね8時20分頃からの後半戦
配信予定となっておりますのでチェックし
てくださいそして
SNSもハッシュタグドリームゲームで
盛り上げていただきたいというふうに思い
ます
会場でご覧の皆さんもYouTubeで
配信をご覧の皆さんもぜひ最後まで楽しん
でいただければというふうに思います
さていよいよ本日の主役たちの登場が
近づいてまいりましたまもなくね会場内が
暗くなりますのでご来場の皆さんは
足元に十分お気をつけていただければと
いうふうに思います
さあいよいよドリームゲーム2022が
始まっていこうとしていますがコート上で
はですね
映画ソニックザムービーソニックvsの
CMではじめしゃちょーと共演した
ソニックも
クリエイターチームの応援に駆けつけて
くれているということになりました
ありがとうソニック今来てくれたけど
ブレイブサンダーそのマスコットロールも
ね一緒に盛り上げてくれているということ
になります
いいですね
さあ
盛り上がる準備はできていますでしょうか
全力でね楽しむ準備はできているでしょう
か
恋に出せない気持ちは
ぜひ大きなクラップに変えてコート場まで
届けていただければというふうに思います
[音楽]
選手
ヘッドコーチのご紹介です
[音楽]
背番号を押しますはじめ社長
背番号を64
水溜りボンドカーター
[音楽]
背番号の剣レース
背番号22パワー
背番号7いやー
[拍手]
[音楽]
背番号12
神戸
勇者
[拍手]
は65コムロットクーラーター
[音楽]
[拍手]
ご紹介でした
川崎ブレイブサンダース
選手ヘッドコーチのご紹介です
背番号を0
無事馬
[拍手]
[音楽]
果物27
熊谷名古屋
の
冗談秘密
突き起こりますヘッドコーチは
スタート
ケンジー
[音楽]
[拍手]
ように並列をお願いいたします
はいというわけで皆さん
本日は僕たちの試合のためにお集まり
いただき本当にありがとうございます
というわけでただいまより
クリエイターオールスターズ対川崎
ブレイブサンダースの試合海賊でーす
[拍手]
さあそれでは両チームウォーミングアップ
を開始してください
改めていよいよクリエイターオール
スターズ対川崎ブレイブスタンダース
白熱のバトルが
幕を開けようとしてしまった
会場からはねー大きな歓声が上がっている
わけなんですがはじめましょうはいまず
クリエイターを出した皆さん公式をいかが
ですかはいそうですねちょっとなんか様が
第3の主席の宇宙を痛めたらしいのでそこ
がちょっと心配なんですけれども皆さん
相当やる気いっぱいというか
コンディションは抜群だと思いますいい
ですね
じゃあもうせっかくなのでねちょっと
クリエイトチームのお話をはじめさん交え
ながらちょっと聞いていきたいというふう
に思いますはいじゃあちょっと読もうかな
[音楽]
よろしくお願いします
患者さんどうですか調子はいやえっと
やっぱ大きい会場で
バスケすることもないんでそうですよね
とんでもない緊張感ですねこれは
ソニックもいるソニックも
お客さんが5000人
満席ということで本当ありがとうござい
ますありがとうございます今日は
袋相手ということで多分思ったような動き
ができないと思うんですけれどもそうです
でも3回とか
みんなでね予定を合わせてしっかり練習し
てきてるんでそれが出せればいいなと思っ
てますそのね頑張りましょう頑張り
ましょう
じゃあ次は
床屋
[音楽]
お願いします
もう
国立チームのイエスですよいやーちょっと
ねやとしてもやっぱ緊張しますねそうです
ねこうやってのお客さんの前でやるのも
初めてなんでだけど俺たち24時間待って
やってるんでそうなんすよもうソウル
メイトなんでここはソウルメーターはい
いやあんだけ練習しちゃうねやっぱ
ちょっと
結果残していきたいですねはい
頑張りましょう頑張りましょうお願いし
ます
お願いしまーす
じゃあ次サワー
腕は大丈夫
いやーこんだけお客さん入ったら痛みも
なくなりますよおおもうやるしかない
でしょいやもう
安定した3ポイントが本当に
武器だと思ってるんでまあそうですね今日
はまあ3ポイントもそうですけど何よりも
こうがむしゃらに
下向きに頑張る姿をしてくれた
皆様に見てもらいたいなと思っております
そうですねちょっと腕だけ気をつけながら
そうですね
全力でやりますOK
無理してくれ
スクリーン
食らいましたけどね皆さんこんにちはやん
でーす
どうですか緊張してますね
すごいね
本当に
緊張してますかいい
緊張です
いやーもうほんと身長もあるし1番若いん
でもう若さを生かしてとにかく
30分間40分間
走り出てきますよろしくお願いします
頑張ろう
こんばんはー
お疲れ様に言ったな
緊張してますか
めっちゃしてますやばいなんかこの
相手の黒の圧力がヤバすぎてそうですね
もう
[音楽]
我々クリエイターとしてもオール君ね
ありがとう
ございます
本気で来てくれるということで
我々もできることを頑張りましょうそう
ですね今日の
目標はやっぱスリーポイントを入れる1
本でもいい
気がするから俺はありがとう
ございます
頑張りましょう頑張りましょうお願いし
ます
目標というかこれだけはこの試合でやり
たいみたいな目標ってありますかまぁ
ちょっと
綺麗なパスを出して
皆さんに貢献できればなと思っております
ありがとうございます先生にも結びつく
ように
期待しとるぞ
頑張ります頑張りましょう
[拍手]
というわけで田口さん僕もそろそろアップ
に行きますあとはよろしくお願いします
はいわかりました
ちょっとでどうでしょうクリエイター
チームなかなか緊張感もあるかなあという
ところになりますが
温まった体もう最初の1秒から
全力でプレイをしていただきたいなという
ふうに思うんですがちょっと実況席にです
ね今
トミーさんの姿がないんですがトミーさん
どこいますこちらです
クリエイター電池に僕は今います
実はですね今日
クリエイター応援団を呼んでいるんです
到着したようなので呼びたいと思います
皆さん盛り上がる準備はできていますか
クリエイター応援団の皆さんどうぞ
[音楽]
[拍手]
すごいね
応援団で
応援団でこのメンツ
そんなことある
[拍手]
[音楽]
こっちが
クリエイターオールスターズの
応援席こっちですねはいこの
熱気的に
すごいホームな感じであのプレイできるん
じゃないかなって思うので
ぜひ
あの勝つとこが見たいので皆さん
頑張ってください応援してます
ということで大和してくれましたコメット
応援してくれます
じゃあ400円いきますか400円いるよ
はい
皆さんこんにちははじめしゃちょーの畑の
岩井先生です
今日はうちの社長が暴れてくれることを
期待しておりますので
田中君頑張ってください
ということで畑も応援に来てくれました
そして一番いいこと
雰囲気変えたグループがいるなあ
えっと
伸ばしそうかなちょっとお話伺いたいと
思いますちょっとどうですか今日はどう
いった
集団で来られたんですか
すいません国籍変わってました
ちゃんと理解者が隣にいるタイプの
やんちゃでですじゃあ今日は冷静も応援に
来てくれましたこの3組が最後まで応援し
てくれます皆さん一緒に盛り上がって
ください
僕まだある
はいということで応援団の皆さんと
ちょっとねお話しさせていただいたところ
でえー
応援団の皆さん今来たところですけども
えー
練習の年収はパッチでしょうか
え僕ねあの改造中の
応援のねちょっと見ていたんですが
まだまだみんな盛り上がれるのかなと思い
まして最初の皆さんもう一度
プレデターチームの応援を
練習したいなと思います高森さん繰り返し
の応援のねお願いできますでしょうかはい
じゃあリピートですねお願いしますはい
それでは
クリエイターオールスターズ応援もう1回
行ってみたいと思います
先ほどですねブースターガールのおっさん
方が出ていただいたんですがこの期間も出
ていただけますかねもしいらっしゃるなら
わかりやすいと思うんですけどもちょっと
難しいのかな
じゃあちょっと
ローズにやってもらいましょうね
わかりましたはい
えーとそれではですね
ご来場の皆さんこれから
食堂を流します今回は
クリエイターオールスターズと川崎
ブレードバスはそれぞれに1つずつ応援
データがありますんでね
長嶋で曲に合わせてこういうやつは
男子で
クラブをして
お願いします
[拍手]
[音楽]
もうちょっと大きいので
試合中にいただければなと思っております
んでよろしくお願いします
特に大声ですこの
対策として天国は天一とさせていただき
ます
とさせていただく場合がございますので
皆様ぜひとも
専用のですね手拍子に変えてエナジー注入
どうぞよろしくお願いいたします
ありがとうございますはいお返しますはい
これでも街ですね
声は出せませんが心は一つ観客席も一覧と
なって選手を応援しましょう
クリーンさんの皆さん大いに盛り上がって
くださいそれではよろしくお願いしますが
辻さん
選手の皆さんのコンディション今ご覧に
なっていかがですかいやーそれでも
凄まじいこの会場の雰囲気が
とてつもないんですが皆さんここは
川崎ブレイブさんがその
ホームアリーナとどろきありなですなので
川崎ファミリーも
負けてはいないはずですよねはい
黒田から関係ありません見てください
背番号0枚の藤井選手
メガネギンギンなんですよ決算そうですね
もうこの上なく千走しておりますね
はいそして27番のね熊谷選手も
メガネギンギンなんですよこれ今藤井選手
ですねはい
熊谷選手上がりますか
熊谷選手もちょっと映してほしいんです
けどね
眼鏡ギンギンなんですよ
藤井選手
対決楽しみにしてたのにというコメントも
残しているんですがこれわかりますか
じゃあもう千葉知ってますよもうなんかね
ゆうまるお城とこれは
すごいこれはね
奇跡の解放が行われましたはい
情報入りましたよどうですか化粧はさせ
ない
ですか
迫力のコメントです
優しいそういうところがね熊が選手の
悪いなあ
しょうがないね
ほらなんやねん
俺一体どう呼ばれてきたっていう顔して
ますけどね続く
手川させないけども俺は行くぜっていう
決意表明ですからカメラを探してくれて
ますね今さすがファンサービス皆さん
ホームコート
川崎ブレムです
よろしくお願いします
[拍手]
クリエイターオールスターズの紹介ですが
はじめ社長がバスケットボール経験のある
動画クリエイターを集めて結成した
クリエイターの最強チームということに
なりますセッション7名です
お気に入りの初めて社長ですが動画中4年
生で出してを始めて高校生の時には富山県
の列島16人進出した実力者です
バスケットボールはずっと続けていきたい
趣味と語っています
川崎ブレイブサンダースのホームゲームに
は
過去に2回テストとして来場しています
そして水溜りボンドの監査はお兄さんの
影響でバスケットボールを始め中学高校と
打ち込みました
川崎市出身という縁もあったのではじめ
しゃちょーどういう意味ですね
過去に川崎にゲストとして2回来場してい
ます
レイクラの智也をですねバスケットボール
歴は14年特技はバスケという生粋の
バスケ付きです
ウインターカップベスト8進出や大阪国体
の選手選出を果たしているということに
なります
川崎とはショート動画でのコラボ経験が
あるということで
さわやんの澤は身長193CMと
クレイタオルスターズ1の高身長です
ウィンターカップベスト8東京国体優勝と
いった実績を持ち
川崎の松田選手前田選手
能見選手とは大学時代に
対戦経験があるということです
さわやのヤンマーお兄さんのサワさんに
憧れてバスケを始め
インターハイやウィンターカップにも出場
しています
憧れのバスケ選手は
十勝府
浜選手と上げています
そして今度のユートも兄の影響でバスケを
始めた選手です
武器は3ポイントシュートなアニメ漫画は
川崎が舞台のアヒルの空ということです
そして今度この裏では友達の影響でバスケ
を始め武器はミドルシュートと豪語してい
ます
7月に有馬から明らかに改名した時は
先ほどもありましたけれども
川崎の藤井優馬選手が
有馬対決を楽しみにしていたのにと残念に
なるというコメントも出ていました一方
川崎ブレイブハンターさんの紹介です
Bリーグ一部所属のプロバスケットボール
クラブです
寺の創設から70年以上の歴史を持ち
リーグ優勝は4回天皇杯の優勝は5回
果たしています
シーズンは
前年に引き続いて天皇杯で優勝しクラブ
市場初の連覇を達成しているチームです
さあそしてえー何人かちょっと選手を
ピックアップしますが
えー背番号0は藤井優馬選手ですね
昨シーズンキャプテンとしてチームを牽引
しています
無尽蔵の体力とアグレッシブなプレーが
持ち味で
ビーズも個人勝で3年連続で3冠を受賞
昨シーズンはレギュラーシーズンのMVP
も受賞し日本代表にも選出されました
先日初めて社長とYouTubeで
ワンオーマン対決を披露したというところ
になっています
そしてもう一人ですね
背番号なら篠山竜兵選手
7シーズン連続で川崎のキャプテンを務め
6度の優勝を経験しています日本代表でも
キャプテンを務めたことのある選手です
益城ファンには有名な神の左手を持つ男で
勝負どころでシュートを決めてチームや
会長を盛り上げてくれること間違いなし
ファンサービスにも定評のある
川崎のシンボルとも呼べる選手で
さあま両チームがこれからガチンコで勝負
するわけなんですが
クリートチームですね
各クリエイターのYouTubeでも公開
されている通り何十時間もこの試合のため
にハードな練習を積み上げてきました一方
の川崎は
奥期間が開けてチーム練習が始まった
ばかりなのですがまあこの辺りの
コンディションの差がどういう勝負になっ
ていくのかなというところ
クリエイター最強チームVSプロ選手と
いう
誰も見たことのない戦どんな結末を迎える
のか
皆さん改めて楽しんでまいりましょう
以上見どころ解説のコーナーでした
[拍手]
さあそれでは選手の皆さんは
報告リアお願いいたします
[音楽]
をお願いいたします
[拍手]
[音楽]
手元であのちょっと生配信も吹いてるん
ですけどこれ今増設
21万人見てます
21万人デビューするんですか僕の21万
ますがこの試合に注目してます
21万人の皆さん改めてねはいこの試合を
楽しんでいければと思いますはいそして
会場の盛り上がってねいただけたら嬉しい
ですねはいありがとうございましたさあ
クリエイターオールカーペパーズです
いよいよ
[音楽]
リップオフです
[拍手]
[音楽]
これはこれは
クリエイターチームの攻撃から
どういった戦略を持ち合わせるのがさぁ
[拍手]
まずはいかがですか
[音楽]
[拍手]
得点をゲットしたいな
もう一度川崎特攻リアです今後も決めて
いきます
いやこれ今見ました
探索のこのディフェンス
本番さながらですね
当然負けるわけにはいきません
顔は神経
[拍手]
野望でも完全について入ってますね一気に
来ました一気に来ました
智也が
さあこの3は
変えてあげる
1本目の3です
前から充実しますからすごいことですよ
これ最優太が運んで
もう一度初めてから
ここはペイントから
これは何を含めたんですかね
改めてこのルール海賊もねいただきながら
試合を見守っていきたいと思います
高校はまだ入りません
試合時間は1分と30秒をすでに経過して
いるというところ初めから
どうですかクリエイターチームですが
まあでも惜しいシーンが続いてるんでなん
とか1本目が入るとねそのー
[音楽]
BGMが違うらしいですねこれ水溜り
ボンドのBGMなんで
ね
ー
[拍手]
[音楽]
よーしゃないですね
えー当然でプロにも黒の石があります
[拍手]
[音楽]
これはさすがですね
作中さあここで第一コースが終了しました
川崎ブルームファンダースがリードをして
いますさあここから2分間のインターバル
ということになりますがハイライトで試合
を振り返っていきたいと思います
[音楽]
[拍手]
盛り上がってますね
すごいですか
ねもう喋ってる
んですね
本当にハード箱を重ねて
本気で勝ちに来ているクリアらしいんです
からね
いやもうほんとトップ3つ練習したんだっ
てくらい時間ない人が多いですけどこの日
のために
仕上げてきてるなっていうのは
川崎選手の交代です
生産
[音楽]
[拍手]
改めて楽しみですね楽しみですね
グループのチーム接触合成です
[音楽]
[拍手]
さあ第2クォーターです天下が付いている
クリアカーチームはどこまでくらいついて
いくことができるのか
さあここ
もっと
大陸を多忙ブレイブサンダー注意を切り
ます
いやしかし本当にともや選手動き
素晴らしいですよね
[音楽]
[拍手]
見ています
この
[拍手]
ショット
川崎バーを
さん
本当に川崎はマジのガチですね
ヘッドフォンの
佐藤健太郎が
ディフェンスをしっかりしろという指示が
出てるんでしょうね
そこから切れ込んできて
本当は
動いてますねそうですねあとは体力の心配
もありました
またボール来ている
一度下げるそしてしまい
どうしようもない3がここは
あります
どうでしょうねもう一つクリエイター
チームエンジンを上げるためにどんなこと
が求められるといやーでも考えてると思い
ますねここで何かこうクリエイティブ
クリエイター的な発想は1個出てくるん
じゃないかなと思います
[拍手]
これはハイライトですね
素晴らしい未来ですやっぱ発想力でね
切り崩していくのがやっぱクリエイター
ですから
なるほど上でもこの発想力を生かしたい
[拍手]
[音楽]
喜びを
予言開拓が塞がないですよなんでだこの
野郎
しっかりしろこのより
激も飛んでいますもうね皆さん今本当は
言いたいことがございますからね
[音楽]
大したの
チームにタイムアウトというチームです
からね
はいここでなかなか変わるからですねはい
[拍手]
気づけば20代164です
ねー
これまで振り返っての2つのご紹介お願い
します
[音楽]
戻りましたはい
はじめさん戻ってきましたね
[音楽]
しっかりとOK
さあこれでまた天才が開きました23対
16そうですね
行く
[音楽]
といけないか
速攻で来る速攻でくる
[音楽]
試合2本目の3用に抜いています
マキュアリングあと20秒ですねさあ第2
ポーター得点で終わらせることができる
サプリメーターチームそれが走れ始めさん
が持ったどこを見る
残り10秒になります
[音楽]
26対16で
川崎ブレイブサンダースがリードという
状況です
さあということでここから10分間の
インターバルに
入りたいと思いますがトミさんちょっと
ここまで振り返っていかがですかいや
ちょっとこんなことを言っていいのか
わかんないんですけども思ってた100倍
前線しているというかこれは
ひょっとしたらあるのかななんていうふう
に思ってきましたねちょっと我々に期待を
抱かせるようなねそうですね
全員こうなんか光るところがあったという
かなり
調子の良いサワーもいるしいやーまさか
ここまでやるとはねー
[音楽]
[拍手]
さてさて
田口さんここでですね先ほどまあここまで
ね
前半を終えたという形なので
手元の集計によるところなんですがはい
川崎ブレイブサンダースの
選手で
0番の藤井悠馬選手ですね
先ほど辻さんからもねちょっと紹介があっ
たんですけどもまだ3ポイント1本という
状況なんですがまず
昨シーズンのリーグのMVPなんですねで
合わせて
天皇杯でもMVPを取っています
そして3年連続3巻
すごい
数字ですねすごいことになっていますはい
で
昨シーズンは
川崎ブレイブサンダースは東地区
昨シーズンは東と西で
カンファレンスがあって行われたんですが
その東地区で2位ででチャンピオンシップ
に進んで
準決勝まで進んだその
牽引者の一人というのが藤井雄馬選
ご紹介させていただきましたありがとう
ございますはいいやー本当にまあ粒ぞろい
素晴らしい選手を擁している川崎ブレイブ
サンダースその本拠地轟アーリーで
会いたいしているということですが
トミさん
改めてまここまでのプレイ
クリエイターチームで輝いていたというの
はやっぱりサワーですかねいやかなり
サワーがこうなんか引っ張ってくれてこう
テンションも沢のおかげで全員上がってる
のかななんて思いましたねそのベンチに
いる時も声すごい出しててかで地声なのに
多分マイク通してる僕より声が大きかった
んでちょっと
元気印だなぁと思いましたねやっぱり
声だけでは負けないってなんか言いました
からね
すごいですねいやでもこれでようやくね
また体も温まっていますから
第3コースは第4クォーターという
スーパープレイに
期待したいなというところになります
辻さんから見て今日ブレイブサンダース
動きがいい選手はやっぱり上段品質選手が
ねあの引っ張ってくる最初に
シュートしたアリウム断行したちょうど
いい選手ですねまああの浄土品選手を筆頭
に引っ張ってきてくれてるんですけど
ちょっとまだ
プロの選手たちがエンジンがかかってない
んで
後半
第3口座からグッと上がって
プロという力を発揮させてもらえると思っ
てますはい
後半も全く目が離せないというそうですね
これは素晴らしい展開になりそうです今澤
選手のお話出ましたよねここで
ご案内としてはですね
増田選手前田選手とこれまでに学生時代に
対戦経験があったというねそのあたりも
含めてこの試合にいろんな経験が
落とし込まれての対戦となっています
ストーリーがあるんですねここまでですね
本当にこうねもう
面白い試合になっているわけではあります
が
続いてはですね
本日のイベントを盛り上げてくれるゲスト
にご登場いただきましょう
YouTube登録者数が460万人を
超えた大人気ユニットスカイピースで
どうぞ楽しみください
[音楽]
[笑い]
ありがとうございましたー
ありがとうございました
[音楽]
[笑い]
バスケのこういうことする時に
スカイピースの曲元気なんで絶対僕はもう
スカイピースにやってもらいたいなと思っ
て
嬉しいです今日勝てそうですか
ボコボコにされると思いますけど10
点差ですで後半なのでまだ
俺たちは諦めてないというかこれからだと
思っているのでちょっとスカイピースの
みんなで会場も元気になったと思うので
ありがとうございますどうですか
かっこよすぎて
気まずい
あの普通にいつも遊んでる
友達なのにかっこよすぎてそうなんですよ
ねまた
次回やるときは2人も参加お願いします
うわー頑張ってください
スカイピースお二人でしたありがとう
ございましたありがとうございました
ありがとうございます
さあということで概算交差のパートまで
守り1分ということになりました
改めてこのようにしたかいやーもうすごい
ですねここで出てくるんだっていう
盛り上がりましたねーなその吹いてました
からねそうですね
びっくりしましたびっくりしましたあ
ずっと持ってでもみんなもね多分ここへ来
てバスケだけじゃなくてスカイピースの歌
も見れるっていうねまあその
盛り上がって後半もね頑張って応援して
いただければと思いますしこの間にね
休んでクリエイターさんがねまだこう
思いっきりプレー楽しんでいただければな
と思います見てくださいよクリエイター
チームのベンチを
誰も笑ってない
部活ですね
部活ですねあれで3年間暗く共にしてます
ねあれなるんですか
田村さん芸人の顔じゃないですよねもうね
はいそうですね
ずっとバスケのことを考えてる人の顔して
ますね
そんな田村ヘッドコーチの情報をお届けし
ましょうお願いします
吉本バスケ部
玉突き5
そして大阪府の北区ベスト32の実績あり
ますさらには
櫻井MVP
殺菌犯MVPはよくわかりません出所は
わからないですはいという情報が入ってき
ていますありがとうございます今回
ばかりは
芸人という方が気を捨てましてただただ
監督として
チームを勝利に導く存在となっています
さあ第3クーター始まる前の点差は26
対16です
富さん改めてこれは逼迫した状況になって
ますねそうですねいやーこれは
後半後半というかその第3クォーター
見ものですね
富士山ただこれブレイブサンダースも
ちょっと後半またいやカチッと入ってき
ますよね
顔を見てくださいめちゃくちゃ真剣な顔し
てきましたねだから多分裏でめっちゃ怒ら
れたんだと思います
怒られたかに注目すんのやめてください
もう皆さん大人なんで
ファミリーの前で
負けるわけにはいきませんのでねはい枕
ですさあということで
選手たちがコートへと入ってまいります
田口さんここで川崎ナンバー18蒲田裕也
選手の情報をお届けしますお願いします
武器はショルダーですあの肩幅見て
ください
素晴らしい肩幅を持っておりましてそして
ポケモンGOが好きですあーそうですか
そうなるとこれ田口さん共通項ありました
ねありましたね
先日ね大きなお仕事をロンドンの方でされ
ていますだけどもねちょっと後ほどお話を
してみたいなというふうに思いますそれ
から好きなキャラクターはカビゴンだと
いう情報が入っていますさあ
ほのぼのとしたBGMから今
ボールが入っています
そういうことなんだろう
川崎のプレッシャーが強くなってきました
よなるほどさあ
ブレイブサンダースの攻撃から幕を開け
ます
この子は冬は何でしょうかはいこれはです
ねファールですね
クリエイターチームの
ファールが今ございました
64番ですね
ファール1つ目です
さあここは決めていけるかカチカ盛る
[音楽]
ですかいやまだちょっと見えてないところ
もあるんですけども
元気に見えますけどねまず1点取ると流れ
がこっちに来て
緊張も柔らかくのかなと思いますねさあ
この6ショットまたもゴールキーパー
カット
がしっかり
[音楽]
ですさあこれでまた検索が開くという状況
になります
クリエイター
早く得点から
息を尽くしていきたいさあ
ここは弾かれてしまえ
[音楽]
ちょっとこの第3クーターブレイズ
サンダースがやりたいことをやっています
か
素晴らしいから
この者の二人にしている囲まれている
ダブルからなんとかオールキープ
初め切り込んでいく
これに召喚
[拍手]
[音楽]
がしっかりとフォローを当てています
このショット
大きなクリアチームです
第3複合者は
試合時間間もなく3分ほど帰るという
ところおー運んだ本当にボール出したこれ
は
惜しいあと
少しなんですか
逆に
川崎は落ち着いて落ち着いてしっかりと
温泉を決めて3
[拍手]
番目の種類を入れています
辻さんが
止まりませんねはいもうね本当の
試合中にもマッドタイミングのね
ジャニーズ警報って言われてるんですよね
それが今もう大いに発揮されてますねさあ
これはチャンピオンでここからしっかりと
しゃべりにして
リバウンドです
[音楽]
ジャニーズ
中に切れ込んでから
前か
もう一度
チェックに入るんですかこの上から2
番と絡まない
川崎の攻撃が続く
[音楽]
前田選手そろそろ決めてもらっていいです
かね
[拍手]
もう閉めるキルしますよ
首に入るまだ1人で生きて振り込んでいく
よー
[拍手]
流れが可哀想ですねどうりが流れを作り
たいんですが
そこはしっかりとボールはいや奪えないか
前からキープ
からここをスティールして
川が行くか
言うたりボールが当たれ
早く
走れもう一度しかし
ジャニーズ
[音楽]
ステーションからポジションアローは
川崎となっています
いやトミさん今意地でも始めゆっくりたく
ないというプレーでしたね
意地と意地のぶつかり合いが
いや本気でやってねいただいて
るってことですねプロの方にもはい
ありがたいことですねさあ
第3クォーターは残り1分と闘病
14点差がついています
竿を縮めたいクリエイターチームここも
始めたものだったさあどうだ1人で行くか
を見て
進学校
[音楽]
[拍手]
さは調子いいですね
船いや今のはじめのうまいこと
素晴らしかったですよそうですねやっぱ
ここもしっかりときれい
になりたいやったー
[拍手]
反対も決めてほしいですねー
[音楽]
もう一度画面が切れ込んでいってキースが
繋がらないしかしまだ川崎ボール
残りは10秒になります
さあクリエイターチームボールを巻いたが
ここで
[音楽]
シュート
が終了です36
対22またもリードを奪った
川崎ブレイブスタンダースが優勢です
この後2分間のインターバルに入ります
さあ第3クォーターちょっとまたトミー
さんあのう月離される格好ですね
苦しかったですねま依然としてちょっと
タワーがやっぱ起点となってんのかなとは
思いつつまあもうちょっとね
元気にプレイして
流れをつかんで欲しいですね
辻さん
ブレイブサンダースはここ突き放しました
いやーちょっと前田選手が3ポイント全然
入ってないんでねそれ何とかして欲しい
ですよね1本ぐらい決めて欲しいなもう
なんか6本なのかな
んで
そんな前田選手の情報をお届けしますはい
好きなキャラクターおじゃる丸です以上
ですありがとうござい
ます
強い情報が出てきました
これがいい方向に見てくれるんですね
改めさんの目から見て
プロのプレーというのは間近で見ていかが
ですか
迫力がすご
い
でしょっていうのがどんどん飛び出してで
もびっくりしたのはクリエイターの応援に
勝るぐらい
川崎の応援も強いなっていう
声援が大きいですねありがとうございます
辻さんがその
ファミリーの皆さん
めちゃめちゃ熱量高いですね
熱いですねコードですから
すごいです本当にでもくれたチームの応援
もそうですねー
しかしその
熱気も残すところはたった一つの
クォーターで決着がつくということになり
ます
ねそうですね
川崎選手でございます
[音楽]
[拍手]
がここが奪ってきたこのまま決めるかー
いこの試合やってまいりましたね
[音楽]
[拍手]
登録を稼働中も譲りません
[音楽]
[拍手]
さあ逆回廊
川がボールを呼んでいるところからもう
一度こう引きます
近い鳥になるさあどこから攻めるか
ゆたこのショット
欲しいですねこれも惜しいところ
[音楽]
さあなんとかボールを奪ってくれたチーム
得点を奪いたいんですがその
様20点ほど
[ __ ]ますからもう一度すれば
ここは入れない
ちょっとだけ
[音楽]
ちょっとこれクリエイターチーム疲れも
見えています
[音楽]
けどここはやっぱ発想でカバーしてほしい
ですねそうですね何かここから勝てる企画
はあるのかどうか
ボールを張ってクリエイターチームさあ
一切手を抜く即位はありません
当然で川崎ブレイクさんです
[音楽]
[拍手]
素晴らしい制約がない選手
[音楽]
ちょっと発想力でね突破してほしいです
ここはやっぱクリエイターなんで何かしら
考えてると思いますねしかしこのパスも
カットされてしまう藤井のショット
しっかりと決まる
[音楽]
さあここでタイムアウト
ニューバー34タイムアットオール
スターズ
トースター
の本気というものを見せてくれましたね
そうですねー46
対22という数字が出てどうちょっと今
これ審判がクリエイターチーム側に行って
いますけれどもそうですねまあちょっと
何かしらの打ち合わせなのかわからない
ですけどなんかちょっとプレイに不備が
あったかもしれませんね
考えて動いてると思うんでいやクリの
気さくという部分がねそうですねここから
どう出てくるのかと今のコースは出て
なかった分なんかはじめさんも考えてたと
思うんでねちょっと待ってください何か
ポケットに何かちょっとカメラは真ん中の
ようにしてくださいね
[拍手]
すいません審判の浅井です
皆さんに一つルール変更のお知らせをさせ
ていただきますなるほどこのタイムアウト
上げですねタイムアウトからクリエイター
チームの得点が3倍になります
承知しました
待ってくれよ
クリエイターチームですよ
これもう何だよそれって顔してますけれど
もちょっと
川崎も
[拍手]
これダメでしょうという声が
ハーゲンダッツの件数
ですよ今戦ってますねー
ポケットに入れるなあ
いいんですか
条件を飲んだということですね
そんなことないですよ
[拍手]
皆さん勘違いしないでくださいね
[音楽]
いやーということでじゃこれは
クリエイターチームの
発想力ということになりますかまぁどれの
こと言ってるかわからないですけど
審判が決めたことなんでですね
特に関与してないと思いますけども
審判の方がルールをちょっと変更したいと
いうことですねあくまで審判がイエスと
いったものが適用されるということで
頑張ってほしい3倍です
じゃあ3ポイントだったら9点になると
ですね
検査は14点差あっという間に覆る可能性
がありますはいなるほど
えげつねなじゃ偶然クリエイターに有利な
ルールだったってことですねそうですね
偶然なんですねこれはあの今全体で言うと
24点の差があるんですが3倍になります
よねてことはですね3
ポイント
始まりましたね後で話します
[音楽]
と思っています
得点が3倍になった状態からのスタートと
なります
さあどうだ初め3こんにちはもう一度
リバウンドまだある外に出るこの石狩の
ショート
[拍手]
[音楽]
盛り上がっていきましょう
[拍手]
残り290秒
携帯31グレイルサウンドアップ狩人
外に出してタワーこの位置は
やめていきましょう
と思いますねどうにかスピードボールを
奪っていきたいというシチュエーションな
んですがこの
[音楽]
試合
この形ださあどこにかどこにボールがさあ
がいた
戻したところ
飛べない攻め込んでいってことになって
からのこのコントロール
決めていく
[拍手]
智也今ので6点ですかね6点を獲得で
[音楽]
ーすこの
衝動だ
楽しいですね
突然のルール変更にも移動塗りしません
しっかりと
得点を考えております
残り試合時間は1分になります
3倍ルールですクリエイターチーム
[音楽]
小屋攻めていく
もう一度
ここでタイマークが設計されます
[音楽]
得点差は20点という状況でソニーさん
いやー本当に先生の戦ってるはじめさんに
ねやっぱこうお疲れ様と言いたいですね
ここからまた1個発想力で突破していくん
じゃないかなと思いますね
本当にこう気持ちのいい
スポーツマンシップが見られるし
スポーツマンシストはこういうことなんだ
なって思いますねやっぱりいやー
突然の
ルール変更あったりも関わらず
サンダース
の見せ方ですからね
[音楽]
[拍手]
チーム一丸となって戦うという姿勢ですね
これは高くなったボールを奪った3点が
3万円だここで6
点が3倍だと思います57
回43これは可能性ありますねーですね
なぜなら7人いるから
やはりこれ強いチームは人数が多く見え
ますねー
[拍手]
[音楽]
1.2秒の残り時間
おかしいやろいや今監督
ですよねさあ一軒リペアの登る時間です
ラストプレイになりますさあ
最後の最後で芸人いたしましたね
ここで
[音楽]
試合
でしたね
最終結果57回52ハンドルは
川崎ブレイブサンダー
それでは天使の皆さんコート中央に並列を
お願いいたします
[音楽]
さあということでいや本当に見ごたえの
ある
素晴らしい試合でしたけれども
選手の皆さんにちょっとお話を聞いてみ
ましょうかはじめしゃちょー
ブレイブサンダーソロの試合いかがでした
かはいもうこの
プロのコートそしてお客さんがいっぱいと
いう状況で本当に前半見ててもらったら
わかると思うんですけども
手が触れてみんなシュート入んなくて
すごいこういう状況でプロの方はいつも
試合されているんだなって感動しました
はいいい試合でした
[拍手]
ズルしてすいませんでした
ありがとうございました楽しかったです
潔いコメントが
飛び出ましたもう一人ちょっとじゃあお話
伺ってみましょうか
総選手ちょっとコメントをいただけます
でしょうかさあすごいよいやー
バスケ最高ですね
今年は日本で
NBAの試合も
開催される予定なんで
本当にこれからもっともっとリーグも始め
とどんどん盛り上がっていけたら嬉しい
です
僕たちYouTuberも頑張ります
ありがとうございましたありがとうござい
ました
いや本当これみんなにねお話聞きたい
ところなんですがちょっとお時間もあると
いうことですのでこの後会場では両チーム
の選手からグッズのプレゼントコーナーが
あるということですのでこちらも楽しみに
していてください
後半戦もねあるということですので
まだまだまだまだ楽しめます20分間の
休憩を挟みまして
再開予定ということになります
後半戦ははじめしゃちょー率いる
レジェンドチームVS
米谷率いる新世代チームの試合ということ
になります
生配信をご覧いただいている皆様
後半戦は川崎ブレイブサンダースの
YouTubeチャンネルで配信いたし
ます20分の休憩の間に
川崎ブレイブサンダースのYouTube
チャンネルでは
前半戦のハイライト
クリエイターチームの選手の意気込み
インタビュー映像を配信いたしますので
このまま川崎ブレイブサンダースの
YouTubeチャンネルへ移動いただき
後半戦も盛り上げていただければという
ふうに思います
この後を引き続き始め社長&川崎ブレイブ
サンダースプレゼンツブリームゲーム
クリエイター最強チームがプロバスケ
チームに挑んでみたをお楽しみください
それでは
改めましてはじめしゃちょーから最後に
一言いただきたいと思いますはい
えーすいませんちょっと
YouTubeの配信丸ということで
めちゃくちゃに最後してしまったんです
けどもあの本当に楽しい試合であの
国立も全力で
全力を出せたと思います
本当に見てくださってありがとうござい
ました
引き続き僕たちも含めてバスケットボール
で盛り上げていければいいなと思いますの
で
川崎ブレイブサンダースもえー
クリエイターも応援の方よろしくお願いし
ますありがとうございました
ありがとうございました大きな拍手をお
送りください
さあということで配信ご覧の皆様ただいま
ご覧いただいている前半戦の配信が終了し
た5分後から
川崎ブレイブサンダース公式
YouTubeチャンネル生配信が
スタートいたします
前半戦のハイライトもありますので
チャンネルを切り替えてお待ちいただけれ
ばと思いますそれでは
後半戦でお会いいたしましょう
[音楽]
それではYouTubeの選手はお戻り
ください